- During certain periods of my life,
I have a very difficult time focusing
on pretty much anything
important or difficult.
During these periods, it
seems almost impossible
to break out of the social media limbo,
where you're just constantly
switching between tabs,
refreshing pages, kind of waiting
for something interesting to happen,
like for someone to post a cool photo
on Instagram or something.
You're kind of waiting to be entertained.
But if you actually
have to apply yourself,
it's extremely difficult,
borderline painful, to do so.
And I'm pretty sure almost everyone
can relate to this problem.
I'm sure you've seen a
lot of videos on YouTube
giving you little tips and tricks
as to how to focus better,
including my own channel,
but there are very few
videos kind of diving in,
talking about why it's so
difficult to focus on hard things.
You know, like, what's the deal?
Why can't we just sit down
and do something important
with very little strain?
Why aren't we motivated to do the things
that would significantly
advance us further in our lives?
Because it's not like we
don't want those things.
It's just hard.
So in this video, I want to
dive into why we procrastinate,
why it's so hard to do important things,
because knowing how this all works
helps us carve out a long-term solution.
It can help us permanently
solve this problem.
And that may sound really ambitious,
but I do believe it is possible.
But, first we kind of have to discover
a little bit more about our human brain.
So, weird thing about our
human brain, our human brain;
I'm really trying to
convince you that I'm human;
the weird thing about the brain is that
it pretty much hasn't changed
for thousands of years.
We share, for the most part,
the exact same brain as our
hunter-gatherer ancestors.
And this is the type of brain
that was evolved to scan vast valleys
for the prospect of food or a fresh kill,
and absolutely light up and get excited
at the sight of an antelope,
so you can gather your friends together
and run after it, kill it.
This is the kind of brain that,
as you're kind of going
through a berry bush
and you find a juicy berry,
you're super excited.
You eat the berry and it
pretty much makes your day.
You know, it's not really exciting stuff.
There wasn't a lot of
stuff to do back then,
but that's just kind of the way it was.
And the reason why we were motivated
to go run after an antelope
or eat a fresh berry
is the same reason,
wow, is the same reason
we're motivated to go on
Facebook and, you know,
check our notifications,
go on Instagram, et cetera.
The reason why we're motivated
to do any of this stuff
is because of a brain
chemical called dopamine.
Now, you've probably seen
a lot of videos on YouTube,
if you're into self-improvement,
about dopamine,
but dopamine is kind of misunderstood,
because most people think
it's the feel-good chemical.
It's a brain chemical that's released
when you're experiencing pleasure.
It's the reason why you
experience pleasure,
but that's not exactly true,
because dopamine is the
motivating brain chemical.
Dopamine is what's
released when you feel like
you're about to be rewarded,
or when you feel like
you're about to experience
something pleasurable.
When your ancient ancestors
saw the antelope frolic
across the field, they
got a squirt of dopamine,
which motivated them to go kill it.
When you see a notification
pop up on Facebook,
you get a squirt of dopamine,
which motivates you to click it.
And what this means is that dopamine
is what controls your motivation.
- Thank you, boys.
Oh, did you get a big McChicken?
- [Man] Yeah, you said McChicken.
- Now, why is this important?
Despite the fact that we
share the exact same brains
as our hunter-gatherer ancestors,
we don't live in that world anymore.
We live in a world of
super normal stimuli,
through ferocious
technological advancement
and capitalistic ventures, or
whatever you want to call it.
We live in a world where
things are designed
to be as pleasurable as humanly possible.
And what super normal stimuli does is
it hijacks our natural reward pathways.
It tricks our brain into thinking
we are about to do something
so important for our survival
that we have an almost irresistible urge
towards doing that thing.
A good example of this is junk food.
Food is integral for our survival,
and high-calorie foods are usually
even more important for our survival
because, you know, they'll
keep us alive longer.
The more calories, the longer
we'll live, roughly speaking.
See, what junk food does is
it's mechanically engineered
to be as high-fat,
high-calorie as possible.
So, when we get that beautiful,
when we eat that beautiful potato chip,
our brain remembers that.
And the next time we see
a bag of potato chips
at the grocery store, there's
a huge amount of dopamine
that's released, motivating
you to go grab that reward,
that reward that's
integral for your survival.
So, we almost become slaves
to our dopamine system.
We almost just go where our
dopamine system tells us to go.
That's why we get into
kind of social media binge
because our brain is telling us to stay
on these social media sites,
because there's a chance
that we might get a reward.
We might get social validation,
or we might be able to look at something
kind of stimulating and naughty.
It's the dopamine system that's telling us
and motivating us to stay there.
So, what does this all mean
if we're bringing this all together?
Basically, for most of us
who have difficulty focusing
and we find it really, really
difficult to be motivated
to do harder things, that is only because
we have reprogrammed our brain
to fall for this super normal stimuli
rather than normal
stimuli, natural stimuli,
because it's not that
these natural rewards
aren't rewarding, they're
just less rewarding
than the artificial super normal rewards.
So, the long-term solution
to be able to focus
on boring things, is
to reprogram our brain
to remember that these things
are actually pleasurable,
and really good for us, and
integral for our survival.
And this isn't just about a dopamine fast
for a couple of days
or something like that.
We almost need to reset
our baseline long-term.
We need to think about
how much stimulation
we want in our lives.
What kind of super normal stimulus
do we want to take part in?
You know, I've noticed in my own life
that when I'm camping for
a long period of time,
and there isn't much to
do other than figure out
how to cook a fish over a
fire, or set up my tent,
or go for a walk in the woods,
or go swimming, or lay on the sand,
in these situations, little things
like having a conversation
with a sibling or a friend
becomes immensely pleasurable.
It's the same reason why people
who break out of an addiction cycle,
they stop doing their
immensely pleasurable thing
cold turkey, after a
certain amount of time,
they find an increased
enjoyment out of life itself.
Pretty much everything in
life becomes more enjoyable.
They start to find motivation
to do things other than their addiction.
You know, it's something
that I also noticed
during the quarantine,
why it was so hard for me
to find my work ethic again.
It's because all that time inside
made me an Internet addict.
I spent so much time looking at screens
that my baseline of
dopamine and stimulation
was so high that the more boring things
became almost painful to do in comparison.
The disparity of
stimulation became so vast
that I felt physical pain
trying to do harder things.
So, if we're able to find a way
to genuinely enjoy the things
that make our lives better,
then what are we doing?
Like, why don't we just go and do that?
I really want to challenge you guys
over the next couple of weeks or months
to really think about how
much stimulation you want
to invite into your life.
You know, what's actually
adding value to your life?
And can you reduce the amount
of super normal stimuli
that you're indulging in on a daily basis?
You may actually find that by reducing
your amount of time on
social media or on YouTube,
or eating junk food, or you name it,
you may actually come to
genuinely look forward
to socializing.
You might actually look
forward to reading a book.
You might actually be
motivated to go to the gym.
There will be that dopamine driver
pointing you in that direction,
creating an irresistible
urge to go to the gym,
like, who would have
thought that's possible?
And it is as possible 'cause it's science.
One way that I'm going to make sure
I stick to this over the
next month, at least,
is I made a list of a
large amount of things
that are fairly low-stimulus that I can do
instead of doing a more
stimulating alternative.
That includes things
like going for a walk,
reading a book, talking with a friend,
Skyping a friend, going to the gym.
By having that list in your hand,
you'll have a automatic response
to that urge to go do the thing, like,
you know, eat a bag of chips or something.
So, I'll make a followup video
on my second channel on how that all went.
I really encourage you
guys to do the same thing.
And if you're looking for more activities
that don't overstimulate you,
then I'd highly recommend
checking out videos on Skillshare
and use it as an alternative
to watching videos on YouTube,
because YouTube is like candy.
If you eat too much of it,
you're just going to feel not so good,
whereas Skillshare is
like a hardy steak dinner.
It tastes good, and it's good for you.
For those of you who don't know,
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of classes
covering dozens of topics,
everything from photography,
to cooking, to coding.
Skillshare empowers you
to accomplish real growth.
And that's because their
classes are extremely practical.
I'm taking yet another
cinematography class on Skillshare.
And I find it really easy to just take
what I'm learning on Skillshare,
and apply it directly to
my real-life pursuits.
And one of the other great
things about Skillshare
is that it's extremely affordable,
especially when you compare it
to online classes or workshops.
If you pay for the annual membership,
it comes in at less than $10 a month.
So, it's kind of a no-brainer.
And Skillshare is doing this awesome thing
where the first 1,000 of
you who clicked the link
in the description below
will get two months
of Skillshare premium, absolutely free.
So, make sure you click below
and take advantage of that.
Learn something new,
explore your creativity,
and have a great time.
If you liked this video,
make sure to hit Like,
because when you hit Like,
the algorithm blesses me
by shoving this video in
front of other people's faces,
helping them out, which also helps me out,
so it's kind of a win-win for everybody.
If you're lurking here, and
this is the billionth time
that you've seen my bald head,
what are you doing?
Hit subscribe already
and make sure you hit the bell icon,
so that you don't miss future videos.
And if you haven't discovered
my second channel yet,
I will link that in the description.
I'm posting kind of weekly
and bi-weekly Q and A videos.
They're super Mimi, super fun.
And I'll occasionally
post blogs there as well,
so make sure you check that out,
but that's kind of it for today.
Thank you so much for watching,
and we'll catch you in the next video.
(mellow techno music)